hey what's up guys i'm kbhd here and as
you can already tell i am out here in
las vegas for ces 2020 and there's
actually some good stuff here already as
you've seen from my tweets but i want to
share something cool with you while i'm
out shooting some of the other good
stuff so oneplus is here with
a concept phone so they're calling this
the oneplus concept one and it's in
partnership with mclaren they are not
planning to sell this exact phone as it
exists here and they don't have a date
for when this tech could end up in a
phone potentially but they're showing it
off like this is pretty much classic ces
it's a concept of something cool in tech
that you might not ever sell but if you
do then that would be cool but what
better time to show off something and
make a nice little wave of press so the
oneplus concept one under the hood it's
essentially a oneplus 7t pro and if you
dig around in the settings it says it's
a different build number in the software
and a slightly different model number
but you can see what we're talking about
here and then with some more mclaren
themed stuff going on the papaya orange
leather and stitching the gold colored
metal on the rails instead of the normal
black but for the main piece the main
reason why this is a concept
is the disappearing and reappearing
cameras on the back
it's pretty cool
so all right what is actually happening
here so for the glass in the back of the
phone oneplus has taken the
electrochromatic glass tech that we've
seen in the sun roofs of some supercars
specifically some mclarens and actually
show this in the video of the quirks and
features of the mclaren gt they have
taken that tech and shrunk it all the
way down into the thinness and the form
factor of the glass
on the back of the foam so the way
electrochromatic glass works is this
shade is created when electric current
is passed through it so there are
multiple layers of glass here and
getting all that glass over the back to
be thin enough to work on a smartphone
but still achieve this effect is
technically really impressive and it
took them they told me 18 months of work
already to get it to this point so i
can't imagine it's easy now if you look
closely or at the right angles you can
still actually kind of see the camera
lenses here and there through the glass
so it's not completely 100 opaque it's
more like 90 something percent to me it
seems but it's pretty clearly better
looking when it's darker it's overall
sleeker when that shade is closed and to
me it just makes the phone look better
it looks cleaner that way and then open
up the camera app and 0.7 seconds later
you've got yourself a working camera
that's totally see-through and it almost
makes this like animated looking
cross-dissolve sort of effect when the
camera app opens which is neat so i was
having my fun opening and closing it
turning it on and off seeing it sort of
hide the camera and reappear but bonus
feature for my fellow video nerds it can
also act as
nd so if you're outdoors or in a bright
environment you can actually go into pro
mode in the camera app and up in the
corner on the concept 1 you have this nd
button and if you press that the shade
will give you three stops of nd from
this electrochromatic glass kind of like
sunglasses to your camera as you've
probably heard it called uh which can be
really useful in video if you don't want
to mess with shutter speed to lower your
exposure so you can actually see it
working here as the iso goes up and down
from 320 to 1250 as i turn it on and off
so it's definitely really effective now
it's not variable nd or anything crazy
like that it's just basically a yes or
no to one level of nd but hey three
stops of physical nd built into a camera
phone
i mean that's that's not something we've
seen before that's why it's so
impressive that's something i'd expect
from like a red hydrogen one or
something like that but obviously that
didn't happen so kind of cool to see it
here so selling all this in phones right
now would be extremely expensive and
that's my main guess for why this is a
concept now and not a feature of a phone
that they're going to sell but
that being said it's something they're
going to continue to work on and hey
maybe as phones get more and more
cameras and get uglier and uglier
weirder looking camera bumps this
becomes something that actually makes a
little more sense you know make the
phone a little bit thicker flatten out
the camera glass on the back and you can
hide exactly how many cameras you have
and put as many as you want in there and
the design doesn't have to get any more
weird so if you look at it that way it's
kind of this forward-thinking move where
if you imagine maybe like a samsung
galaxy s 15 or you know some phone in
the future with like a dozen cameras you
never have to see all those ugly circles
on the back if you have this
electrochromatic glass then you can just
put as many cameras in the smartphone as
you want and it'll always look sleek on
the back so i thought this was
fascinating either way that's it for
this one just a quick hands-on and a
first look but definitely be sure to
follow on twitter and get subscribed of
course already if you haven't for more
ces stuff coming up thanks for watching
and i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace